well joining me now is uh israel's
ambassador to the united kingdom zippy
hotel valley welcome to you
boris johnson prime minister as you know
has appealed for restraint on both sides
uh what's israel's response to that
request
well first of all let's describe the
situation on the ground israel
is under attack under heavy fire from
hamas a terror organization that is
targeting civilians uh i just spoke to
my parents my mother over 60 years old
woman had to go into a shelter she lives
in the center of israel a few minutes
away from tel aviv the whole country is
undefeated
we appreciate we appreciate it you need
to understand where israel is standing
at the moment
there well i want to talk about that but
i do just want to ask first of all about
about what the prime minister and indeed
others in the international community
have said is this a time for israel to
show restraint no it's a time to israel
to protect its citizens and we try to
show uh restraint and to de-escalate the
situation few days we did it with all
measures possibly can a country a
sovereign country can do but look at
this synagogues were under fire
yesterday in the heart of israel you
cannot ignore the
as the united nations says
moving towards all that war
united nations its duty to say that
hamas is committing a double war crimes
one war crime is their shooting from
civilian
areas and the other one they are
shooting two civilians so they are
committing doubt as you well know the
united nations has repeatedly said that
the settlements are illegal in
international law and should cease and
those are continuing but they need to
condem her organization which is
recognized by britain and by the united
states that is now shooting into
civilians
a bit rich to say the united nations
should do something when israel is
ignoring what the united nations has
said in the context of settlement can i
ask you something what would you do if
britain was under a fire what would you
do if london was under fire and rockets
were thrown on your house what would you
do do you think britain would have sit
in silent not protecting its citizens do
you expect any sovereign countries of
course of course you can protect
citizens
the question is the retaliation
and the attacking of civilians in gaza
and elsewhere which as we know once
again is leading to disproportionate
suffering uh on the palestinian side
well the the big disproportional is the
fact that a whole country which is
israel is shattered now and kids cannot
go to school and have a daily routine
because
kids are under attack and schools are
under kids in gaza can't go to school
and they're being killed so tell tell
their leadership to stop inside but it's
israel no no no it's the hamas sending
the rockets it's
israel which is countering with the air
force with the strikes which you
acknowledge are in civilian areas
because you blame hamas for using
civilians
as shields but it is i've come back to
this it is disproportionate that there
are more people suffering on the
palestinian let me give you i'm a jurist
by me in my background so let me give
you the international perspective of
that by international law
israel is respecting the international
law according to international whenever
you're under a war with a terror
organization you can shoot to the
targets in order to destroy the
facilities of this terror organization
that's what israel has been doing for
the last two days in order to protect
even even if it results in significant
civilian cases we're doing everything we
are doing everything in our power not to
harm children if you stop this but we
need to protect israel's children as
well if you need to understand if you
stop the attacks you wouldn't be killing
uh palestinian children so you expect us
just to have fire on our cities and our
children and do nothing do you expect
that from a sovereign nation not to
protect its citizens this is what you're
basically saying i i say people who've
been victim of terror attacks countries
who've been victims of terror attacks do
not always respond in the way that
israel is
i've seen many countries that were under
terror attacks they were always
protecting their citizens definitely a
democracy like israel who protects human
rights and one of the things we are
obligated to do
to make sure that israelis won't be
honest
you say
you're acting defensively but there are
those who say
that this is a situation that was
provoked by the israeli authorities by
police going into the al-aqsa mosque by
the use of stun grenades
by uh stopping uh the
free movement in uh jerusalem i'm very
happy you're mentioning that because i
want to answer this question
that the police overreacted i want to
answer what's happening on the ground
and what's the reason we've seen the
picture we've seen for many years
ramadan month this holy time of the year
thousands of muslims were praying and
worshipping on temple mount nothing
happened never in the past for the last
many years that israel has freedom of
worship to all religions what happened
this year so the reason that we've seen
this uh act of violence from hamas is
because of internal political debate
between hamas and the palestinian
authority the palestinian authority have
made a decision
i'm not sure everyone everyone is aware
of the fact what's the trigger you said
you wanted to talk about what happened
in jerusalem i'm answering you what's
the political name behind the violence
i'm asking you on behalf of the israeli
government would you accept that
there was overreaction and indeed
brutality by the israelites absolutely
not absolutely not and i i can tell you
why because what is uh out of proportion
is the incitement of hamas leadership at
the moment that is trying to take the
leadership of the palestinian people and
instead of seeing their leadership or
the palestinian authority leadership
calling to people to calm down and to
stop violence we see the opposite we see
them inciting people in israel but again
citizens of israel against jews
we see them calling for holy and
religious again this is what's happening
i understand that
using this political crisis
in order to harm israelis and civilians
what i'm asking you about israel is mr
netanyahu exploiting this political
crisis as we know
he's only the acting prime minister
because of inconclusive elections he's
worried about losing office because of
possible prosecutions he might face
and that whipping up a security
situation or allowing a very dangerous
security situation to take place maybe
simply a cynical way of saving himself
all political leaders in israel today
want israel to respond to hamas
aggression and to hamas attacks on
israeli civilians because this is what
every country is not in the way that it
is so no in a way actually actually
actually some people say we're being too
gentle some people say we're being too
gentle as long as our our cities are
still under fire we've been probably too
gentle because we need to stop those
rockets being fired on our cities and
our civilians and our children and i let
me share with you a personal story i'm a
mother for young children and i remember
myself sitting in the middle of israel i
live in rehovate it's where the weizmann
institute is it's a very famous city i
remember myself taking my baby daughter
to a shelter because hamas was shooting
rockets
very well palestinian families with
children remember being forcibly evicted
they know that the law as it's currently
being applied to the claiming of
property in east jerusalem is biased
against the palestinians basically they
have no rights and jewish people you
cannot buy this excuse you're too
serious for that you know that this has
been a legal case it's been going on for
years so it cannot be the trigger this
year isn't it because this is a legal
case that israel has asked the court not
to not not to actually give a verdict
now because it the tension is so big but
i can tell you this is a legal decision
he's been going on for years so it
cannot be the trigger the real trigger
is the political debate between the
palestinian authority and hamas but it
also stands doesn't it that the
two-state solution cannot be possible so
long as the settlement program continues
and and the claiming of east jerusalem
can it look at gaza hamas is shooting
from gaza no settlements in gaza as you
know because israel withdrawn 2005. what
was the results more radicals took over
and they're shooting rockets on the
heart of israel they're shooting rockets
on television
what i'm saying is they're wrong
there's provocative behavior
by the israeli police arguably uh
supported by the netanyahu regime and
we've seen the demonstrators on the
streets saying you know kill the jews
kill kill the arabs actually it's the
arabs calling kill the jews
and also
israeli jews saying kill the arabs get
the arabs out i can tell you that
whoever says kill someone this is the
role of the police to take them into
prison because this is illegal but if
you're coming back
how many jewish people have been
arrested all i can tell you that we we
have equal alone
we have equal law for everyone and
everyone is doing a violent protest is
being in jail but i can tell you that at
the moment the provocaters are the
leaders of hamas a cruel terror
organization that is trying to kill my
children my brothers who are
sitting in shelters at the moment so
this confrontation just goes on right no
it can it can stop the minute hamas
stops shooting rockets on our cities
israel wants to live in peace as you
know we've been living in coexistence
for years let me tell you another
personal story i grew up in lod this
city that we saw those marches yesterday
those synagogues going on fire for many
years jews and arabs live completely in
peace what happened it's hamas inciting
those people or the citizens of israel
instead of living in coexistence to the
opposite to act in violence to commit
crimes to
put synagogues in fire those are this is
vandalism against holy sites
no sovereign country can accept it has
to be said as a diplomat you're not
really offering much diplomacy i'm
offering justice i'm offering the
justice of my country what i'm offering
at the moment is make sure that everyone
in britain will say what would i do if
rockets were firing to london and i
believe most british people as a
democratic society that cares about
human rights would have said no country
can tolerate rockets being fired on
children's
schools
thank you very much indeed thank you
let's hope the situation can be resolved